my name is uh don webbie i'm technical
evangelist with devexpress and uh yeah i
hope i can give you some more
inspiration on uh some maybe some
optimizations in your own code
i'm going to be talking about
generics and abstract classes in c-sharp
and typically not on how to
use existing
generics and abstract classes but how to
set up your own
generic classes how to deal with that
and i'll show you uh
how you can actually optimize existing
code so i'm going to be showing you some
code and i'm going to refactor that and
you'll see
that there is a lot of redone and code
gone at the end of this session
and i hope i give
yeah that that'll give you some some
inspiration to to take a look at your
own code and maybe you can put in some
optimizations yourself
so let's let's first start uh on an
abstract class and by the way this this
code can actually be applied on all
sorts of c sharp projects whether it is
blazer or net or net core or
it's it's a generic yeah it's a generic
thing on the dot-net framework
or in the c-sharp language typically so
let's let's first start on what is an
abstract class well uh has
is there any of you that didn't use an
abstract class before
ah most of you did cool
all right so it is typically a class
which
which does not which has a declaration
but doesn't have an implementation on a
specific member
so it is also typically a
a type
which serves as a base for a class
hierarchy
and it cannot be instantiated because
it's obviously not finished yet
and
yeah a simple example i had to
freshen up your minds a bit
i have
a bit of code here and what you'll see
is i've got a shape
which is marked
the class itself should be marked as
abstract here
and it's got a
a an abstract property in this case
which is called the area
so that one is abstract as well
in the tostring method i'm actually
using that
that area property
but i don't know at this stage what it
is
so if i would scroll a bit down
i will now have the rectangle shape
which is derived from the shape and
what i've done is i have implemented
that area property which is in this case
the width times the height so it's
pretty straightforward
and i didn't need to redo the two string
methods well same goes for a circle as
we all know
the area of a circle is calculated
different from from the rectangle so
this is in a nutshell what an abstract
class is and you can apply this on
methods properties
of a class
but what you'll find is when you
when you combine this with
generics
you'll see that that the design time
experience inside visual studio as well
as visual studio code
gives you quite a couple of really nice
features that enables you and your
co-developers to write code more
efficiently
because it's all uh yeah very very nice
done but you'll see that a bit later
so let's let's uh let's take a look at
the generic type so what is
generics well
it is it is
yeah it's it's more like a coding
template
okay so you can define a class which
holds some types that you might want to
change later on so maybe it's got like a
property of a specific type but in a
in a descendant class you might want to
have another type of that particular
property
and what we can do is we can create some
sort of a code
template a compiler code template
and
it is
once you master this technique it is a
really efficient way for reusing code in
a typesafe way and that is one of the
most important things because that saves
compile time errors
because it is all strongly typed if you
set it up properly
well
obviously this is
giving you a compiler error
and this is considered to be type safe
because the compiler will already
complain you're declaring an integer and
you're trying to put a string into it
and that will obviously not go
an unsafe way of
getting rid of this issue is by not
declaring that that variable as an
integer but as an object because you can
store everything in it but then you'll
lose a couple of great features
inside visual studio
because now official studio yeah you can
do whatever you want visual studio won't
complain but you'll encounter runtime
issues
right and with generics you can solve
that really really nice
and also the compiler and the net
framework deals very efficiently with
generic types
there are other languages and
development environments as well that
have generics but
yeah i mean
the c-sharp or at least a.net runtime is
dealing very efficiently with it so it
will actually treat it as a generic
class and it will only at runtime
instantiate
a class
where you where you
specify the generic and it will it will
not do a lot of overhead for that and
that is that's something which is really
cool
well
i'm pretty sure that all of you have
been dealing with generics by now
because obviously
the.net framework uses a whole bunch of
generics
only to start with a startup file where
you configure all kinds of things
that is typically all using generics
the list
of tea is a
much used thing
uh that is generic as well i mean you
can put whatever type in this list
but what we're going to talk about is
how we can create our own class which
will use generic types as well
a tuple is an example
the function and the action are really
cool things
which are are are used quite a bit
in the internals of the framework as
well
and then obviously the dictionary is a
great example of
generics as well
with the later versions of.net core
there is the span of t to deal with
memory
allocations and so on
well as i mentioned
the configuration file i've
let me open up my visual studio and show
you a small
application here
so if we can see this is uh
this is the program file now i should
actually use the startup
startup file for this
and what we see is there is a whole
bunch of generic stuff going on here
already configuration of entity
framework uh a whole bunch of other
things so
yeah it's it's really really
really a good thing
all right so
yeah
let's let's see what we can do to to
create that generic code and let me see
yeah
let's let's uh switch over to visual
studio now
all right so
what i've done i've set up a small demo
application and uh
the application is set up to be using
entity framework it's nothing nothing
exciting there i'm connecting to the
chinook open data open source database
which also music some invoices and some
other stuff
and i have obviously since
i work for devexpress i've used our
devexpress project template to set up
this application so
this is in a nutshell how it looks it
cut a bunch of invoices here
i also create you can actually edit
those invoices
but that's not really a thing here
i have customers as well
and how did i set this up well i have
used one of the things that come with
devexpress which is a scaffolding tool
i will show you how that works but then
we will redo the whole scaffolding part
in making it generic
and so the way that i did this did this
is
i went to the
controllers let me see if i got the
right project yeah
and i will be adding a controller
in this case
i'm going to be adding a devextreme api
controller which comes with a with our
product
and now because i've set up entity
framework already to connect to a
certain database i will be able to
pick any of those
entities
create a controller
and what it now does is it has created a
complete
web api controller for me
to perform crud operations so i can
i can get the data out of the database
and i can also post
put and delete
and as you can see this has been
scaffolded and
obviously scaffolding can be really cool
because it can save you a lot of time
but if i would take a look at one of the
other
controllers that i already scaffolded
for instance the invoice
controller
you will see that because it's
scaffolded
it's all pretty much the same let me
it is all pretty much the same but
slightly different you see but there is
still a lot of code involved and i mean
it's
all it's a lot but obviously
that's one of the things with
scaffolding i mean it will
poop out like a whole bunch of code in
seconds and it will save you some work
but
once you start
developing or expanding your application
you might
want to change some of the behavior the
behavioral things
and you might want to change the
behavior of the scaffolding and then is
obviously when the fun begins because
you need to change all the controllers
you need to go all over the scaffold
code
and that's not going to be cool
so
this is also where generics is like a
really really nice thing
one of the other things
that bothers me a bit about this
template and i mean don't get me wrong
this stuff is great obviously
but
with such a solution that we offer you
typically don't want to include like a
whole framework to go with it uh it's
it's like a scaffolder
it gives you an idea on how it works and
you can start customizing it from there
but if we also would ship out like a
whole bunch of base classes you need to
get into that as well so
for this purpose this is fine
now but for like a real application if
if you use it for a prototype it's fine
but if you want to get on with it and
create like a bigger application i would
certainly
yeah check whether it we can change that
one of the other things
which is
yeah something which i would not
encourage
is
the results of this get
this is returning an anonymous
object basically
so this is
there is no design pattern involved in
dto maybe you want to perform dto and
and abstract that a bit away from the
from the actual data layer
so
i typically have like two two things to
do here i wanna be able to use the dto
design pattern to transform the data
entities out of the database into like
the objects being returned
and obviously i want to have less of
this
enormous amount of code
and so for that i have also already
configured and implemented
auto mapper automapper is one of the
most used tools to perform dto
transformations
and i've already configured that so in
my folders if you see it in the project
folder i have set up the entity
framework models here i have set up a
number of dto models which also start
with dto
and i mean in this case it's uh
yeah
quite simple but it is just to give you
an impression on how to approach this
and what i've also done obviously is i
have configured the
mapping profile
for automapper and it's obviously nice
to mention that you can see that also
autumn mapper greatly depends on
generics
all right so if you want to know more
about the auto memory configuration
they've got some excellent documentation
and
actually you can
probably still ask
the author because he's on the
conference as well so
you can ask him a dozen questions on
this
all right so
the first thing we'll do is
i'm gonna chop up the data access and
the actual operation on the on the web
api endpoints and for that i have
decided
to also set up
an in this case an ef data store and
this brings us to our first generic
thing and that is we're going to create
a generic
interface
so how do we create a generic interface
well
this is quite simple
i'm just specifying my my interface name
and i can specify a whole bunch of
generic types so in this case i'm using
the t key
and the t model
because that can change
maybe the key type in some scenarios
could be like of a type string or maybe
it's a
a unique identifier or maybe it's an
integer here but this
t
is an important thing that might be
generic
and one of the other things that i've
specified is the model so this interface
is going to be implementing a couple of
things which we'll see later on but we
have this key and this model and this
model is the dto model type
but
we also want to put up a couple of
restrictions so that the key should be a
type which should be
able to be compared with another type
in the store we might need to look up a
certain entity
for
updating or
deleting or whatsoever so we should be
able to resolve that and in that case it
is
one of the things that you can do is
that you can specify a where class on
your
interface declaration
and in this case i'm specifying that the
t key can only be of the type equatable
and what that means is that the key
of the objects that we're going to deal
with cannot be of a type of of a complex
type because they are typically not
implementing the i equatable interface
so an integer can be put in here
or a string or a unique identifier
those kind of types
and also the model
that should not be like a simple type
because we are dealing with dto so we
want to have like a real thing so for
that i can put in a second constraint on
my generic types
and in this case the t model can only be
a type which is an actual class so it
can't be a string
um
it should have a
a constructor without any parameters
that's the new with the uh with the
brackets
so
yeah we've pretty much created our first
generic interface
we're going to be adding a couple of
things later on but let's do the same
thing with the class and the class is
going to be slightly different
because what we'll see here is that i've
specified a bit more
and this this data store will actually
help me this is going to be
something which i can query i can pass
in a dto object and it will make sure
that it will be updated correctly in the
database
or inserted or deleted and so this is
typically my store and my store is
depending on the db context
so that's also why i have specified now
a tef context together with the key and
the model but also the db model because
we need to do the mapping and the system
needs to know how that works
and so for that i have now specified
four generic types
and obviously it is implementing that
same interface and because that
interface has some restrictions put on
those specific types
i need to put on the same ones here as
well so
in this case i'm also putting up a
restriction on the tef context which
should be a descendant of the db context
so we can use this like in other
projects as well
the key is the same restriction as the
interface the model is the same as the
one on the interface and this one yeah
it should also be a class
and obviously entity framework
just deals with plain objects okay so we
can't like make that any
any tighter basically
so now we can actually start using our
genera or implementing our generic class
and also i have made this abstract
because there are a couple of things
that in this base class i don't know yet
and we'll find out a bit later what that
is
um
let's first
put in a couple of things i will be
dealing with autumn mapper and i will be
dealing with the
db context
so i'll use constructor injection
i've set up automapper ndb and the
entity framework
to be available in the dependency
injection so i will be using
the constructor injection to get
references to it and
store them
then one of the other things that we'll
need is
a couple of helper models and this is
also something this is a a really simple
example on how to use your own generic
type
so at a certain stage i need to create a
new model a new
dto model
and remember that t-model that is a
generic type so instead of dealing with
like a real
type here i'm just using one of those
t-model
generic types
and i can actually do this
the new model
i can create a new instance of this type
which i don't know yet i mean it's going
to be happening in a
in an implementation somewhere
i can use this construction to create a
new model because i put up a constraint
this
if i would remove this one
you'll already see
that
i get the red curl the curly line okay
so this is one of the great design time
features that visual studio is giving
you like okay this can't be done if i
can't put up that new thing on the
constraints
i should use the activator create
instance yada yada and the whole bells
and whistles but if i now just specify
that neo in the constraints and that's
for this case it's perfectly fine
it's also fine with the compiler
and so this is how quickly also visual
studio picks this up and it's it's going
away
one of the other things that i'll need
i uh
i need
to locate
an entity
in the database by key
and again what you see here is i'm
actually using two of those uh generic
types which is the db model
as well as the t key type
and i'm just using it as if they were
like real types here and because of the
constraints i can actually use a couple
of things i have specifically pointed
out that the db model
is a class
and i have also specified the db context
of being
of the type tdb context
so that means that i can now use the
find
on the db context
with the generic type that i'm looking
for
and the key
you see so this is actually just working
with the types that you were already
making generic but instead of real types
you are dealing with these generic types
so let's put up a couple of other things
here
this is an interesting as well because
at a certain stage i need to query the
data store to select a number of albums
or invoices or whatsoever
and with this i will just follow the
approach of entity framework and use the
iqueryable
of type tdb model
and i'll just call the generic method
which comes with the db context of
entity framework and i pass in that tdb
model type
and so this is all
yeah
not strongly bound to a specific entity
yet
so let's
see there is a couple of more things
that we'll need and one of the things is
obviously because that is that's one of
the things i want to
query based on the dto object
but then that needs to be transformed
that
run time to the entity framework models
right because at the front i'm dealing
with the dtl objects
and that is also why auto mapper is
getting quite nice so this one will
actually query
based on the t model class you see that
and i've also made this one public
instead of protected
and now i'm actually using one of the
automapper features here
and this allows me to query based on the
dto object on the front but it will be
transformed by automapper into the
entity framework models and this is a
very
cool feature i'd say because then you
are actually abstracting away the data
layer
from the front end
a couple of other things that i
also need to do i need to get back to
this first one because i need to add
this one to my interface which i will do
right now
let's see and this one will need it as
well
so i don't need to
stop it
so i don't need to do that any later
um
yeah let's um
let's put in another one this is a bit
of an odd one and i obviously did show
the entire code that was scaffolded but
here i am actually introducing
a local generic type so this is also one
of the things that will work
in this case this this t
is only generic
available within this methods and still
i'm also able
to
put some constraints on it as well
i'm going to use this as well but we'll
get back to that a bit later but it does
show you how you can actually have like
this one particular method which allows
you to specify
another extra generic type
and
what i can do now is
i can use automapper again
to query based on that
t type basically
projected back to the entity framework
models and then query the database
all right so
this one i should also put straight away
to the interface
let's do that here
so
we have done the query part basically so
we now have a generic data store which
will do that
i will also
want to query
and get a model back by key so in this
case i'm going to be using that create
model method that i declared earlier
and i will locate this by using the ef
get by key
and auto mapper will transform that into
that t model type
okay so this is still all very very
generic code
and for this one we should also
add that immediately to the data store
yeah all right
okay so now
i'm going to introduce you another
generic feature and this is something
that you have used before i'm pretty
sure about it but this is looking quite
quite complex
specifically the declaration
so if you take a good look at this
what i am trying to do here is i want to
execute some function that's going to
happen a bit later on
within a transaction so basically when i
want to update any of the entity
framework models in the database
or delete it or update it or whatever i
want
i want this to happen within that
transaction
and
the interesting thing here is that this
first parameter
looks quite complex on the declaration
side of things
but this actually is a
function which
passes in
that ef data store
with all the generic parameters
and it will return
the type
yeah which it returns but this looks
quite strange but you'll see a bit later
in code
that this is a very powerful feature
that allows you to basically do whatever
you want within this function and return
whatever you want in this function
because of this generic signature
and this is this is done on a function i
have a similar one
this will not return anything but it
will still do something huh so
this
let's go back to this one so what we do
here is i have this work parameter
in this case it is of a type function so
it can return something
and the other one is quite similar
except that instead of returning this t
this parameter will be an action so this
this work will not return anything but
it will just do something within this
transaction there but that perk is going
to be executed here
and then it will do a commit in this
case or whatever
so
the declaration looks
a bit complex but you'll see in code how
this actually works
so let's
go a bit further
before we can use that code there is one
thing
that we don't know yet in this base
class
and that is how to set the model key
on a particular model
so what i'll just do here is i mark this
as being abstract i don't know what it's
going to be i mean for if i want to
update an invoice
i have this invoice model and it's got
an invoice id property but if i have an
album
it might have an album id and so those
properties
are different could be different
but i want my code to be type safe
so that is why i am uh
making this one abstract
and in the in the derived class of this
you will see that it is really not a lot
of work to implement it
i'll add this one to the interface as
well and
stop
reloading
i have another one
which will return the key and it's the
same for the album it can be the album
id and for an invoice it can be invoice
id and again i've made this one abstract
as well
then there is one thing and that's uh
the one
to set
uh to get the key out of the model
because theoretically with dto
you could be working with the entity
framework model which has an id field
but maybe you want to have it on the
dto's album id so those keys could be
different from the model the entity
framework model versus db model so i've
made this one abstract as well
and
now
with these in place
i can
create a generic update methods
insert method basically
and this also brings us to this
transcend transactional execute
with the with the difficult signature to
read
so what i am doing here and this is
obviously quite nice is that this first
parameter work is receiving two
parameters i specified that in the
signature above so
check it out a bit later
and this is the code
which is going to be executed and as you
can see because i pass in those two
parameters here i have access to the db
context i have access to all the things
that i need
to update
that model
and one of the other things that i've
done is i have passed in a
an array of models so i can update like
a whole bunch of them in one go
and so this is that parameter of the
transactional execute
and in this case it is the first one
that was returning the t so that is the
result
uh and but if you want to do something
which doesn't necessarily update or
return anything uh yeah you can use the
other one
and in this case the result
is a type ef result there was a little
class that i put on top of it
and why is that of type ef result
because in the end
i'm returning that ef result
and that is why the result but if i
would return an integer if i would
change this return uh
10 for instance then that t would be
changing an
integer
so this already works design time very
nice
and the ef result is just a simple
object returning success true or false i
mean in a real application you might
want to
check which items have been updated and
which not whatever so you might want to
expand that a bit
but all very
very generic still
well you can imagine that the update
method
is doing a similar thing so i'm not
going to spend too much time on that but
what we'll see here is that we look up
the model key so this brings us to this
abstract method i need a model key
before i can actually look that up
in the in the database
and if i found it i will map it
from the dto model into the entity
framework model and i'll save it
and so again with that transaction
execute method
well
then the last
thing that we'll do here
is the delete methods
well for the delete we basically only
need the ids so i thought okay i'll do
an array of ids
of type t key
and
yeah
pretty much the same in this case it
will do the transactional execute as
well but it will just locate the models
and it will delete it
you see so
then because we want to use create a
weight and async as well i have
put in a couple of methods which will
allow us to async await the same stuff
as well
and with this
yeah we have actually set up our
generic data store
so how does this work in in in practice
basically well
if i would now go to the
invoice controller
i can go to here
no not the invoice controller the
invoice store i've created a class
of type invoice store and what i now do
i'm going to create this class
and this is how i am able to yeah to
implement this this ef data store
in this case it is already specified
that i am using the shenouk database
context which site configured
the invoice entity has a primary key of
type integer
my dto invoice is the class that i will
be projecting on the front
and the invoice
is the entity framework model
now what you also see now is that there
is a couple of
red
scribbly lines and let's first take a
look at this one others a couple of
typos here
let me first get these out of the way
i need to change this in the demo sites
but
okay
so they're all gone
and now they're double
let's get rid of these as well
all right
so and this is a really cool feature
because you already saw it with the
abstract class that i was demoing in the
beginning it is already complaining that
something is not cool here
and if i would hover over what we'll see
is yeah there is some stuff not being
implemented because it was being
abstract
and now you'll get a really nice thing
because if i first say
add
a missing constructor i need a
constructor obviously
stop
can i just stop that thing for
ah okay
anyway so i just implemented the
constructor and what you see is that
that genome context is now used as a
parameter so it is now become strongly
typed
and we go to we take this a step further
because if i now go again to here and i
will implement the abstract class and
this is also quite cool because you know
exactly where you're dealing with
this is the only stuff that i need to
implement
and if i do this i have a full
data store which allows me to deal with
in this case invoices
so
well this is quite
quite simple and what's also interesting
now is that you see that the generic
base type has been closed it's not
generic anymore it is now all strongly
typed
this is the model i'm dealing with
this is another model i'm dealing with
this key is an integer because i
specified it on top so it is
basic
it's it's typically a coding template
once you combine abstract and and
generics together with uh with each
other
and the only thing i need to do now is i
can return
in this case
modeled and i have
everything
available here so this is obviously very
powerful and it saves you quite a bit of
compile time errors okay so let's
say model dots well what was it again
invoice id
equals key
so now i'm actually dealing with
strongly typed
things
let's do this one as well return
model dot invoice id
and yeah with this approach
my base classes don't need to inherit
from
anything that i would need to make this
work now i'm just dealing with generic
types
i now have code completion here on the
specific types that i have been
specifying
and this is the only thing i need to do
so before we can actually apply this on
the uh
on the application
do the customer store quickly as well
and this is typically
it's it's not really a lot different in
this case
i'm dealing again with the new context
integer type dto customer instead of
customer
and
yeah now it's pretty much the same deal
i can just say implement
at the constructor
stop
reloading
and uh
and implements
the abstract class
so now these classes only implement code
that is
specifically for these classes and you
have gotten rid of a bunch of redundant
code
before we can actually apply this on the
application there is another thing i
need to do but i will quickly go over
that and that is the base controller
i've also decided to set up a base
controller
and
again
i will follow the same approach
as i did with the with the store the
base controller has a key type it has a
model and it has a store type so
i need an invoice controller obviously
to deal with invoices i need a customer
controller to to deal with customers etc
okay so again i have now specified that
this t store is only of a type i data
store of t key
t model
so i can't use
the customer store on the invoice
controller because those declarations
don't match
you'll get a design time error
that that won't work
so this is quite safe
coding wise
in this case i will
also
use constructor injection in this
case i need the uh
i only need the data store so let me
quickly insert it like this
and there's a couple of other things
that i will do
in this case
i exposed the data store the primary key
pagination and the primary key
that is something that was in common
in the original codes and that has to do
with the remote paging sorting grouping
but that is more like a devexpress thing
i won't go too much over that right now
but i'm just putting it in
then i'm gonna put in the error message
to get full error messages something
which was in all the controllers so that
was a bit redundant code
so i'm just putting it in here
and another thing i'm putting in here is
the populate model and the populate
model is because the the controller
the invoice controller if you want to do
an update here
it receives json
and that needs to be deserialized into a
model and for that we're going to be
using that populate model thing
so just a couple of helper things here
[Music]
again i do want to have access to the
create model so in this case i could
also call the main data store t-model i
don't know why i did that
and the iqueryable
i make it available
as a method on the controller as well
now we're gonna actually read the yeah
remove some of the redundant codes by
implementing the get method and in this
case i'm not decorating we're not
dealing with it with a controller so i'm
not decorating in this base class
the
method with http gets
i will also not do that
with the post
and the update
and the delete
there was
something that was
why is this giving me this error
should be okay let me see
uh i am on purpose not decorating these
attributes on the base controller
because maybe there is this one
controller that doesn't allow you to
update or insert or whatever so you need
to explicitly do that on the actual
controller which is deriving from this
one
all right so with this in place i still
don't know why this is
do i really need to
do it like this
of course
yeah yeah yeah
i needed to do the await and async
methods i needed to put that
obviously in the interface which i
didn't do
so let me do that right now
all right
okay
all right so all the all those issues
have gone now so i have quickly
implemented a generic base controller as
well which is
dealing with the store so i've actually
abstracted that that original code a bit
as well
so you can uh yeah you have that
separated
and now we can actually start with the
fun stuff um the data stores need to be
configured in this case
uh i will first
in my startup
i will deal first with the
invoice and the
customers i think
so now i can use
the di
to add my info store which will now be
injected in a controller which demands
an eye data store which deals with dto
invoices
the thing the same goes for the customer
store so i've now configured my two
custom stores to be used with dependency
injection
if i would now go back to my controller
we can definitely slice up some code
which is always nice to do
so in this case i will go to my invoice
controller
and i will
change this
to base controller
and as you can see you will have the
full
code
hinting
i'm dealing with an integer
i'm dealing with a dto uh invoice in
this case
and the store is going to be my uh
a data store let me
let me copy that over from the
dependency injection
where was it yeah
okay this should be injected and this
will obviously result in the invoice
store because i configured that
like that
see and now i can let me quickly put
this one aside
like this
i'm not sure why it is now
complaining
yeah so what you'll see is that i have
implemented a constructor and i need to
override a couple of things here
uh this one is still a bit weird why it
can't be found
wait a sec
okay let me switch up
did i miss something there it must it
must be
let me
let me get rid of this
and let me start all over again here so
i was implementing the base controller
and the base controller
deals with the integer the dto invoice
i'm not sure why i can't find the dto
invoice
did i uh yeah i probably uh didn't got
it in the name
yeah i can probably do it like this
all right so yeah we're back in business
wow
yeah
okay so i've now specified this base
controller and
let's
implement the
constructor first to get that all set up
everything is okay here
and now what i can do is i can override
oh no i first need to implement an
abstract thing
override the gets
why do i need to override the gap
because i need to decorate it with the
http i'm i have decided to do that on
purpose because now i can specify per
controller
yeah that it should be available for get
or
something else
then i will do the same
you know what i'm going to copy that one
over from my
finished demo that saves a bit of work
here and there
um
so the invoice controller is
going to look
like
this
this is going to be way shorter because
what i've done now
is i have overwritten
the appropriate methods
and there is one method that needs a bit
of attention i have mentioned that
before
at the beginning when implementing the
store
so let me do it like this
so and that is the customer lookup
but what we'll see now is that we have
actually reduced this entire controller
the code that was in here so all this
code
is all
obsolete basically
and this goes for all controllers now so
i'm not sure what will be faster
scaffolding enough
another controller are just implementing
one of these interfaces
one of these base classes
i mean all this code
can now
go away
because this is the only thing
that is left
and as i mentioned i created this
this query method
with a local generic type remember in
the ef store well and that is because i
need a customer lookup to populate in
the data grid you probably missed it
when i was showing the application
so what we can do now as well is because
we need a customer store here as well
we can actually expand
this one
with having a second parameter well let
me just show you that in the finished
demo because we are almost through our
time as well
this was the invoice controller
so what i've done here is i've just
used constructor injection to get access
to the customer store as well
and instead of getting a full dto
customer object back i just need a
simple object and if i would check this
class up that was already in the dto
classes
it typically just has a value a first
name and a last name while the full dto
customer obviously has a bit more
information so
because of that local type that i used
on the query method i'll be able to use
auto mapper and the configured
auto mapper entities to get another type
of customer object back as well
and yeah so with this in place you can
imagine that you can actually
yeah reduce
quite a bunch of code and in this
particular scenario i have reduced it to
like
what is it five percent of the remaining
code
and obviously i have the base classes uh
prepared to be fully generic and
i can actually implement it strongly
typed on my
actual implementation
and with this in place
what we'll see is
let me quickly put this in so the
application runs again i'll copy this
over
to the other one
here it's starting
to what
sorry
a bit
where am i missing something oh
yeah you're totally right
yeah so
and with this in place we yeah we have
typically the same application as before
when i use the scaffolding feature with
like a whole bunch of redundant code and
the application will still behave the
same
except that it is way easier now for
instance one of the things that i didn't
touch is obviously
maybe you want to do some validation
yeah you could put in
fluent validation or whatever which
works great with with generic types as
well you could actually implement that
into that data store that base data
store and
have that system figure it out at
runtime
um this was not what i was gonna show
yeah
so here we have the same application i
mean for the front there is typically
nothing changed except for the fact that
under the hood we have separated the the
classes that are used on the front and
in the data grid from the actual entity
framework models
and we can have other validation
settings on the dto models
besides and
versus the validation rules on the
entity framework models
and yeah there is a bit of an
abstraction there
but for the front
yeah the application is just the same
and uh yeah so with this this is the
customer by the way so the customer id
is actually a lookup which is calling
that method that i was
talking about you see
and with this
i think we
are i am pretty much done with
explaining what i was going to explain
let me see if the bullets we have
touched all the bullets here
i was going to explain what i was going
to do
yeah
and with this i uh yeah i'm pretty much
done in uh in refactoring my code into
generic abstract classes which allows
you to only implement the
specific differences between
implementations here and there
um yeah and if you want to play around
with this code i mean feel free i have
this full demo including the starting
point as well as the end project it is
available on this github repository
yeah check it out and and see if you can
use it your own applications if you can
optimize your own code and
make your uh
your code a bit more maintainable
so are there any questions so far
in that case
thank you for your attention and